يمكن لظاهره التي يتوقع ان
تتطور في الاشهر المقبله ممكن ان تعكر
مزاج الكثيرين في العالم طبعا السبب ليس
فقط لتغيير مواعيد الامطار او تغيرها
وتغير درجات الحراره ولكن هي تاثيرها على
محصول القهوه تحديدا ولكلا النوعين من
الحبوب الارابيكا
بحسب تقرير لصحيفه واشنطن التاثير سيبدو
واضح خاصه على مناطق العالم المسؤوله عن
انتاج كميه كبيره من الامدادات العالميه
مثل البرازيل فيتنام التي تنتج على سبيل
المثال اكثر من نصف امدادات
في العالم
بالتالي تغيرات ستنقع عفوا ستمنعكس على
فنجان قهوتك الصباحيه والمسائيه فقد ينتهي
الامر بالمستهلكين الى دفع اسعار اعلى
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات